>> Here are samples of size 10 from each of these distributions. So I'm going to
find the first quartile, which we'll henceforth call Q1 for the general
population. And I'm also going to find the third quartile, which we'll call Q3.
First, let's split the data in half. So we have five values above, and five
values below. Then we find, essentially, the median of this half, which is
38,801. So this is Q1, the value of the first quartile. And then we find the
median of the second half, which is 56,863. So this is Q3 and the median we'll
call Q2. And our new range, then, will be the distance between Q1 and Q3. So
18,062, then, is our new range, when we cut off the upper and lower tails. Or
the upper and lower 25%. So now, how 'bout you do the same for this one. Cut off
the upper and lower 25%. This one is Mark Zuckerberg. And then let's find the
range between Q1 and Q3. Put your answer here in the box.